Are you getting away from the
the Glucojel tablets
or going straight to collagen
or you dealing with the liquid Glucojel,
which is better for you?
So, under different circumstances, I'll
recommend different things.
I always do good, better, best, for
example, but I also do what will fit
budgets a little bit better.
Uh collagen is refined gelatin
from multiple sources instead of just
bovine, so I love collagen. Don't get me
wrong on that. But, uh
the straight collagen doesn't have
glucosamine in it. The collagen joints
do, but it's a pretty happy price point,
but it's a great formula.
Uh people are having problems in their
neck and spine.
I seem to have a better success rate
with uh liquid Glucojel 1
16 because there's two liquid Glucojels.
132 16, and they seem to get better with
challenges with their spinal column. And
so, I like that one best in that
scenario. Uh but most of the time, I
start people out on Glucojel, and then I
ask them on their sore joints, on a
scale of 1 to 10, what are you? And if
they say 1 2 3, then I recommend 1 2 3
Glucojels. If they say 7 8 9,
uh
I might get them up to nine Glucojels.
If they start saying 10 11 12, then I
usually go to the joint collagen or the
liquid Glucojel, depending on where the
pain is.
Um the other thing I also ask them is
what their body weight is.
Um you know, if you weigh 325 lb and you
have bad knees, there's another problem
we have to address. We have to get your
weight down. Cuz the mechanics of your
knees isn't designed to take that much
weight.
And so, we we need to work work with
that as well.
Or if you were abusive like I was in
college and played baseball as a
catcher.
You can imagine all that up and down and
I don't have the best knees in the
world.
But I still chase my grandkids.
One's 14 now, he can beat me.
>> [laughter]
>> Did that answer your question, Rod?